good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it's one day it's hump
day Wednesday it's Wednesday it's wet
nest day it's hump day our favorite day
of the week here at the morning toast
because that means we're so close but
also that means you can hump anyone you
want that's in the workplace it does
mean that except that usually you know
we opt to hum Theo but he's not here
today because we have a special guest
also today it's you could probably tell
if you're watching on YouTube it's super
rainy today sleeping Theo when it's
raining I like don't like the oh he's so
messy and like such a mess yeah and
honestly like he's like Jessica from
love his line he's a mess no no he's
just like Jessie smell a a mess he's a
mess a Chinese me oh so so hai don't
like to like a femine I don't like to
hang out then when it rains they know
it's me and I think he definitely feels
like a shift in my my mood towards him
yeah so that's really why he's not here
but also because we have a very
prestigious guest Alexis Neiers Hanes
will be joining us if you don't know a
lot about Alexis I encourage you to go
watch season one of one of a little show
called pretty wild reality show on the E
Network I think they have it on Amazon
Prime I want to search anything anywhere
these days there was also a film made of
her life where Emma Watson played her it
was a little movie called bling ring
well not of her life I'm a very sure
chapter of her life and she will be here
today to talk about all of it and I
can't wait I like one pretty wild aired
on TV I was wild about it like I
absolutely loved the show I love the
sisters obviously like him we didn't
know a lot of the struggles that they
were facing in terms of sobriety and
drug addicts right and also then towards
the end of the show The Bling Ring stuff
comes up and so it was just a wild ride
and I'm so excited to be here in 2020
talking about this ride ya know it was a
crazy reality show because there was
just like this interesting family living
in LA like the young girls were friends
with a lot of celebrities and like the
day they decided to start filming for E
was the day she got arrested and the
whole seat season ends up documenting
her legal troubles but it was just meant
to be like a family realities you know
she just wrote a book called recovering
from reality we're gonna talk to her
about it um soon maybe it'll be the next
TR BC choice yeah perhaps
ooh TR BC is coming up soon
for those of you who aren't in the know
that's the redheads book club it's a
book club that I started with my friends
and my counselor and we're just having a
blast I know you call it TR BC but when
you call it that all I can think of to
you is TCBY I know I call it TR BC but
absolutely nobody else calls it that
what I said to snitch oh are you ready
for TR BC she's like for what oh I
thought it was like a worldwide thing I
mean if you guys feel like I just think
it rolls off the tongue TR BC cher we
see for sure it's like a good assortment
of letters you're a good assortment of
letter morgan ladders you know touch the
morgan ladders oh we got a clip
Bravo released a clip last night of like
a minute of the Real Housewives of New
Jersey episode that's airing tonight and
yeah so [ __ ] juicy it looks so good
we also need to recap the under come
paroles oh yeah you know very boring
episode I totally forgot that it was
even on there but it was a boring
episode but there were some interesting
nuggets and watch what happened five
did you catch it no but um Santa ball
was on was on with the worst guest of
all time
Adam Paley yeah I'm not familiar with
his work I think he's on the Mindy
project and then he's on a new show
called indebted which I'm sure are both
good but he was being so [ __ ] rude
really mm-hmm just saying like such mean
things about the cast of Vanderpump
rules and like it would mean what kind
word oh when they were talking about
Ariana and her coming to Tom saying that
she wants to run away from her life and
they had like just a conversation about
I'm watching happens live in Santa Barta
crying cheering up when he saw the clip
and then they asked Adam what he thought
and he was like he said something mean
about her hat that she's wearing oh my
god right so really at the end of the
episode Andy gave him the distinct honor
of naming of doing the Mazel in the Jack
oh wow and I forgot what he did for the
Mazel but for the Jack Hoel he did
Randall's neck because you're kidding me
cuz he's unsure of what's going on in
there and and it was so uncomfortable
and oh god it was like it was so fat
phobic and I I was truly it was so
uncomfortable
I can't that makes me upset because like
last night's episode was one of the
first episodes we really got Randall
like on camera like Mike died and he was
everything of the sort everything of the
sort like I want to go to dinner with
him and Lala like all the time and just
to know that like now like even on his
own Network like their jokes being made
about him like that makes me really sad
yeah and I'm all for on Sanibel like
wants to be the
Crusader of Venus saying anything like
to raga Tori at any time yet he sat
there and like smirked and you know what
like I understand that it's
uncomfortable but this guy had made like
multiple not cool jokes throughout the
episode and and I could see that Tom's
hand of all was like not cool with it
but then like say something right now
because that's like that's your thing
that's your thing a season yeah say
something oh my gosh wait now I really
need to go watch it that honestly gives
me hope because obviously about
trappings I've is like running out of
guests so maybe just maybe like this is
getting me one step closer to being a
guest yeah also Danny Pellegrino was the
bartender that's how I saw who the
guests were because he posted on his
Instagram because he co-wrote fancy AF
cocktail and it's just once it's a great
set for podcasters yeah I love to see it
and he was really great but anytime they
like threw to the bartender he just had
like snappy answers back about his
favorite cast members
I follow him on Instagram and he posted
a clip from the after show where he got
to like ask everyone questions and he
actually asked like some more insightful
questions like when they dead to me I
was like Andy
housewife I didn't know they were gonna
do it so I didn't have time to prepare
yeah I do think that he knew before his
maybe his answers were just that good
but it seemed like he knew what they
were gonna ask him got it because he
came up with his favorite housewife and
his most underrated interesting and I
just thought he was totally on point so
that that helped the episode but it's a
great step for podcasters it's I just
love to see it so interesting about Adam
Palin
they really brother they watched repens
live like does a show every night with
two guests and they have so many repeat
guests in addition to the Bravo
liberties and they've been doing the
show for a while like I'm sure that they
are at some point going to run out of
guests oh I don't think so really it's
like any type I'd like every single show
that runs every single day like Jimmy
Jimmy's idea but the Jimmy's like you
can reach another like they have
athletes and Bravo has their own values
they have their own Bravo liberties but
I feel like on network late-night shows
like you have a more you cast a wider
net when it comes to talent like Kobe
Bryant was on Jimmy Kimmel like multiple
times I don't feel like any like athlete
really has ever made was on watch it up
inside last week
oh but besides him look I don't really
back was on yeah I remember the iconic
episode when he put his shoe and show
when they did South by Southwest yeah
yeah yeah I just feel like they are
totally running out of guests like how
many times can Kelly Ripa come on oh
that's true and Mark Consuelos don't get
me wrong love them but I do feel like
they're running out of gas and maybe
like our times
oh I mean I would love to see it but
they can always just like recycle
housewives add that those are my
favorite episodes yeah when they have
Bravo liberties so and then like super
fans like SE Cupp you can always throw a
c-cup in really I can always throw Megan
McCain in ya SE Cupp like I can live
without but yeah you know it looks like
they're totally getting desperate enough
maybe just maybe have a podcaster on TV
was just and I think well earlier in the
episode the guy had like he said said
I'm here to like be funny right so I
think he just got a little carried away
yep you know in this climate man like
come on yeah anyways we have a great
show free day we actually have so many
stories I had a hard time whittling it
down which rarely happens on a Wednesday
so I guess without further ado we have a
lot to do today let's get into the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning next and that is true
but before maybe you want to go get
something to eat you're feeling a little
hungry head over to your fridge and get
one of your hello fresh meals to get
started your day
hello freshest recipes are so delicious
you can break out of your dinner rut
with their 22 seasonal chef's curated
recipes every week there's something for
everyone including low-calorie
vegetarian and family friendly recipes
every week they have more five-star
recipes than any other meal kit so you
know you'll get something delicious
hello fresh cuts out stressful meal
planning and prepping so you can enjoy
cooking and get dinner on the table in
just about 30 minutes or even 20 minutes
but they're quicker recipe options the
average trip to the grocery store takes
241 minutes that's over 35 hours a year
if you go once a week their proportion
ingredients mean there's less prep for
you and less food waste the packaging
hellofresh uses to ship your food is
almost entirely made from recyclable and
or recycled content
hello freshest carbon footprint is 25
percent lower than store-bought grocery
made meals you can add extra meals or
lunches to your weekly order or throwing
yummy sides and desserts like garlic
bread and cookie dough easily change
your delivery days or food preferences
or skip a week if needed go to hello
fresh comm slash toasts and use the code
toast n for ten free meals including for
shipping you can only get this offer if
you go to hellofresh comm slash toast
10 and use the code toast ten toas t10
for ten free meals and free shipping
head over to hellofresh comm slash toast
ten sign on get hellofresh eye
love hellofresh you know when my mom
doesn't have time to cook a meal from
scratch she just goes didn't uses
hellofresh
i can't tell the difference hello fresh
feeding campers around the world okay
first story a little more Bravo news I
guess it's just a Bravo centric day
Leeanne Locken is leaving the Real
Housewives of Dallas after four seasons
quote it's been an amazing journey she
didn't ever be with people the hope
their positioning it like she's leaving
I do feel like she didn't have a choice
right which is the classic Housewives
move you know the network actually lets
them all do that until enough time
passes and then they're like no Kara
rads well literally just gonna say yeah
but no housewife has ever really said
like I've been fired yeah Tamara and
Vicki were like oh let go and they
didn't pretend like they weren't ya
that's it's interesting how they let
people like slide yeah I mean they get
to like maintain their dignity I don't
think that Leanne totally chose to leave
I don't know the course not the show is
her life yeah but her statement is that
the last four years have been a trolly
slap in good time but after much
consideration I have made the personal
decision to share that away from Riyadh
getting to share my wedding with the
viewers last year brought me tremendous
joy however the season was very
personally challenging for me I'm
cooking forward to stepping away from
the cameras and spending quality time
with my husband and friends traveling
but most importantly getting back to
philanthropy which was my main reason
for joining the show thank you to
everyone who has laughed and cried with
me along the way it's been an amazing
journey and yes my panty liner is still
exhausting
there are so many things on my horizon
that I can't wait to share with you oh
my god this statement is exhausting like
so Thursday yeah I mean I actually I
can't believe like I can't believe it
she's not gonna be on next season like
she is the Real Housewives of Dallas
right no she definitely had to go and I
think her being on the show from the
gecko never really made sense seeing as
how it is like this you know show where
it's like a higher class of living and
you're supposed to and she never really
like fit the mold but and I know
everyone had their opinions about her
and regardless of how you felt you can't
deny that she was really the center of
the show like every if you look at the
controversies of every season like she
was right at the center of it of it like
she was always willing to like be the
villain and like say crazy [ __ ] and like
do crazy [ __ ] so I do think that the
show will suffer without her but I do
think she had to go I think she had to
go I don't think there's any way that
like carry brooding ham would have
really felt comfortable like being on an
ensemble cast with her and then if they
took carry bringing him off and left
Liam it would say and chose LeAnn yeah
and it just it was too far gone yeah I
do think it's interesting though that
they let her like release a statement
and say she was the one leaving because
I think her circumstances around leaving
were different than other people's like
she like did she crossed a line kind of
how Phaedra seizure was fired mm-hmm and
to me it's like the same level of and
it's the same circumstances as to why
they're not in the show anymore like
what they did on the show was teleport
that like the network can't stand by it
so I think it's weird that they let her
announce it like that yeah well I think
eventually you know the other housewives
will be like sure you know well you know
I'm just talking about like the
narrative around the actual firing like
Phaedra was fired put like publicly but
they I mean if she went to people with
her semen and she posts on her Instagram
and the network it's like they're not
ever really loved it yeah but I'm sure
there's like some sort of contractual
obligation like she she had to been have
been allowed to do this I guess she
didn't just go rogue I guess also
because people has that relationship
with Bravo yeah I do think that they
allow housewives to make the statement
that they want to make and then
eventually they'll air it out but they
didn't do that with Phaedra did they I'm
not sure but they did it with Carol I'm
just reverting this back to Carol oh but
Carolyn do anything wrong to get fired
she just steps back like I'm reverting
it only back to Phaedra because they
both did something on the show that the
audience demanded they'd be let go for
yeah so I feel like that's maybe she did
go rogue I don't know cuz this just
seems so strange yeah I feel that
well justice for Phaedra by the way like
I just would love to have her back on
Atlanta but do you think she'll ever
come back no I think like the audience
like despises her and what she did like
really was like so evil but like we
stand we have absolutely no choice
no we don't we have choice but we choose
the wrong side and I like candy too and
like what Phaedra did was like so evil
like making up these type of rumors that
she like date rapes we would like it was
horrible but like we love her okay
next story like a little celeb of
relationship news it's still a rumor but
I'd say rumor musing to believe
page six is reporting
Harvey Weinstein's ex-wife Georgina
Chapman has moved on with Adrian Brody I
was I absolutely loved if you remind we
have the current marital status of
Harvey Weinstein and Georgina Chapman
exes I don't know if the divorce has
completely gone through but like she's
not taking him back that's like so
embarrassing for her like she was
married to Harvey Weinstein like that's
like saying you're married to Hitler
like it's just like the name is like so
yes
like parsing yeah it's quite parsing so
while Harvey Weinstein is headed to jail
his ex-wife Georgina Chapman is finding
solace in the arms of Oscar winner
Adrien Brody with him dead this is so
cute rumors popped up last fall that
Chapman 43 and Brody 46 were dating and
a source close to Chapman confirmed to
page six that they're still together
while the designer and the movie star
had met and socialized previously sparks
apparently flew when they were both
invited to Puerto Rico for the launch of
model Hellena Christensen's swimwear
line last April held at the swanky
Dorado beach ritz-carlton reserve what
the [ __ ] is Adrien Brody doing out like
a swimsuit influencing absolutely no
idea and so there's a photo of them
across the table and so there it's so it
could be the speculation yet there just
happened to be in the same room but I
personally much like Jim Carrey and
ariana grande before them I'm choosing
to believe it I'm choosing to believe
you too honestly I feel so torn about
Georgina Chapman like in general but I
do feel like she's had a pretty
miserable life and like of course she's
had great successes or business Marchesa
is flourishing but like to have been
married to like that for so long like
she truly deserves happiness regardless
of how you feel about her like yeah I've
gone back and forth with her because I
do get filled when it all came out I was
like she knew she's compliant and now I
remember vote did a very flattering
piece on her and now I feel like you
know nobody had it worse than Georgina
Chapman you know you feel bad for her be
feel like you want to hate her because
how could you not know but at the same
time like what the [ __ ] could she have
done she was married to a monster like
he was in control so like I do really
see her as a victim in all this but a
lot of people choose not to see her that
way yeah I just feel like imagine what
she went through Oh totally and now
she's just like falling into the arms of
Adrien Brody dream brownie the pianist
pianist for anyone who's confused
well not all he's ever gonna be
totally by the way I can take him out of
the Holocaust
yeah we could say you can't take the
Polish no okay so like he's just a boy
from Pope
oh my god I'm [ __ ] dead iconic remix
Adrien Brody is so interesting like
whenever I hear his name like obviously
like the Jew in me is always like Jews
love Adrien Brody like what he did for
that movie and like what he just did for
like Holocaust awareness is so profound
and I think every Jew like wishes their
daughter would marry him like everyone
feels really connected to him and you
would never believe it like I like the
most Jewish person ever like sat next
him at a dinner party and had absolutely
no idea who he was and I was like what
do you do and you know he said close
he said I'm a painter like oh cool let's
see some of your work like I just had to
dinner with cool people and I figured
like he was probably I don't know but
like a really like mr. brainwash like I
thought I was really sitting next to him
like that's sickening would love to see
some of your work like what kind like
painting structures you know and then he
left and someone was like what did you
guys talk about I'm like the painter I
don't know like I was just shooting the
[ __ ] like that's Adrien Brody I'm like
the pianist and I literally will never
forget like how mortifying that was but
I think like maybe it was cool of me
sometimes it is cool yeah you know it
just depends on I think the day in this
celeb that you're talking to you but he
seems super low-key but you know what
now that I think about it like I'm not
entirely sure what he was doing at that
event and what I was at was a Mariah
Carey after-party like why was Adrien
Brody there I just think Adrien Brody
from basically everything I've learned
in the past five minutes it's just he's
not the guy you think he is you know
that's actually said sure he's a painter
yeah like I feel like go see him on the
backside you know like he's I think he's
just so much more than he is obviously a
swim swim wear enthusiast who is her
he's obviously a Mariah Carey Stan of
course and I think he could be our next
Bachelor except that now he's been
snatch lured by Georgina Chang I think
maybe we're gonna see him on the toast
soon is getting desperate I think he
like be on a podcast soon for sure that
seems like they're out he's going down
also like he doesn't work how does he
like make money I think those pianist
residuals future I mean every like march
of the living birthright
trip makes you watch that movies so he's
getting coin all the time yeah I mean it
really is a great movie if you haven't
seen it you should check it out it's
honestly [ __ ] horrible it's horrible
but it's like an important yeah it's
just so painful to watch like when they
throw the guy in the wheelchair off the
terrorists like I'll never forget I'd
stop when he like finds a piano and like
a evacuated village that's why he's the
pianist yeah you can take okay yeah it's
like enough I'm just so grateful to that
story for this morning you know ya know
by the way and if it weren't for the
chose I never would have heard that and
I had like my head like deep in pop
culture news and I haven't heard that
rumor and I'm like living for it
Georgina Chapman is like sickening and
you know what I think when she got
married in Marquesa like wasn't is
wasn't what it is now and I would just
love to see her get married to see what
kind of wedding dress Marchesa would
make fur because Marquesa like is the
end-all be-all of wedding dress the
wedding dress is for sure
um so yeah they're definitely probably
allegedly together yeah I'm so happy for
them allegedly next story you guys so
exciting Keeping Up with the Kardashians
is coming back in March and we have a
sneak preview where Kim is lunging at
Kourtney and khloé is wearing an XL e
sweater i Lauren Elizabeth
is that crazy crazy and there's a new
episode of mood by Lauren Elizabeth so
it's you know there's not actually shot
delays oh yeah she said she'll explain
why she's just lost her house last night
you can listen to last week's so keeping
up was coming back Kim and Kourtney are
going at it with hands saying don't ever
come at me like that
but I thought Kourtney was off the show
so I feel like I feel like we this
season will Chronicle her leading the
show because last season it was still up
in the air she had released a statement
saying the home but we're catching up
with that statement oh I just really got
the vibe that it was all over it was
ending as the season was ending and it
honestly made a lot of sense yeah
on Tuesday he announced that the famous
family's long-running reality show is
moving to Thursday nights one which I'm
so here for by whom I don't think
there's anything right now that we watch
on Thursday yeah you know what I don't
know if I'm entirely here for it because
there is nothing on Thursdays so I feel
like Monday's a bachelor Tuesday
Vanderpump rules Wednesday's always a
housewife sometimes in some overlaps
there's a housewife on a Thursday but I
like that after Wednesday it feels like
the week is really over I I feel that
and Sunday's like our family night you
know yeah I
wonder that's like crazy but I do feel
like to be on Sundays all the time is
definitely really hard because so much
happens on Sundays like award shows
they're always competing with like major
news events for ratings like I'm never
watching Kardashians live because
there's always something else on yeah
unless it's a season premiere right and
Kourtney and Kim are fighting right and
they're like live tweeting and fighting
still so season 18 is set to premiere on
March 26 and in the sneak peak
accompanying the announcement tensions
between Kourtney and her sisters Kim and
Khloe only seem to have gotten worse
since last season why do you have an
attitude demands Khloe in one scene
quote just don't involve yourself in
business that's not yours for pies
Kourtney we got we should do a dramatic
reading totally and then Khloe fires
back then don't talk about it in front
of me
so drama is a Bruin it seems like the
same type of dynamic that was happening
last season where it's really Kourtney
verse Kim and Khloe's firmly stuck in
the middle even though she's on Team Kim
but like won't be vocal about it yeah
it's really frustrating actually I wish
Khloe would get more involved well it
seems like she's getting involved I
can't believe they're throwing hands
like that's when you know they've never
taken this to the level except with the
purse don't be [ __ ] rude yeah so
maybe that's the thing that sets
Kourtney off to not to no longer be on
the show Oh like this particular fight
you mean yeah or something stemming from
it it just seems to like strangely
inconsistent that truly p on the first
episode you know cuz we we like we
closed the chapter like we know she's
not gonna be on it anymore but maybe you
just are watching the seasons
back-to-back we don't know that but she
didn't say that she's not gonna be on it
completely she just said she's like
gonna not be on it less so maybe this is
her being on it less perhaps I don't
know I could just still live for a show
that's just like Khloe and Kim and Scott
and Sophia and Kylie and Chris and
Corinne someone tweeted that Kylie like
dude life of Kylie season two and she
was like should I imagine I would be mad
because like you can't do Kardashians
but you can do life of Kylie agreed
light would be like oh Kylie I
absolutely love Kylie stand like to the
end of time but it was nothing of the
sort
no because it focuses so much on her
friends who look we don't care about no
but like if you feel the need to be in
front of the camera please go in
Kardashian's like they need you they
desperately need her
I wonder if this means like Khloe I mean
Kendall will be stepping up like I
honestly hope not she's just not that
interesting yeah she's very interesting
to look at
but I just feel like she just works a
lot and that's like not that interesting
and she's always just like stress and
when she has free time she's just like
hanging out with her friends like if she
wants to be off camera yeah I feel that
yeah okay well next up a little College
Admission scandal news
well because oh by the way we're going
to LA we are tomorrow tomorrow and
tomorrow and Friday episodes will just
be podcast because Jackie and I just
haven't some you know important dealings
to do in LA some events some meetings
houses to look at because we're moving
there for a six-month sabbatical and
then our flights at 11:40 and I plan on
getting to the airport at 11:35 because
I'm a clear member and so are you we've
mentioned it before we are not the
greatest at getting to places on time or
early especially when traveling and
getting to the airport that miss my
flight anxiety is the absolute worst
thing in the world and I swear I'm like
I've made a vow to myself I will never
be a person who runs in the airport like
I would rather miss my flight than run
but that's why I became a clear member
it's the best stress reducer never run
to your gate again clear helps you get
through security with the tap of your
finger so you can get to your gate
faster reduced pre-flight stress and cut
the line you are your ID you can start
getting through clear through security
in a tap they replace the need for a
physical ID card using your eyes and
fingertips to get you through security
because you're the best ID it's super
easy to sign up you create your account
online before going to the airport once
you get to the airport an ambassador
will help you finish the process and
then you can immediately use clear TPG
has like been telling me about clear for
years and I only got on the clear train
maybe a year ago when I started touring
two years ago and it has truly changed
my life I think it's overall saved me
statistically 1 billion hours at the
airport they get you through security
faster in 65 plus airports and stadiums
around the country with more being added
every day if you're traveling with your
family you can get up to three family
members added to your account at a
discounted rate and kids under 18 are
free when you're traveling with a clear
member it is absolute best way to get
through the airport security it works
great with pre-check too by the way I
have it with pre-checker
Jackie doesn't have a paycheck and
having it with pre-check is sickening
yeah it's sickening but it's even decent
without yeah
right now listeners of our show King at
their first two months of clear for free
go to clear me calm slash toast and use
the code toast that's e le AR M e.com
slash toast and the code toast for your
free two months of clear love it sign
cut the line cut it okay little college
emission scandals news because the hot
pockets arists who was involved in the
college emission she was yes she was a
mother to a student who she bribed to
get into you so the hot pockets
granddaughter daughter granddaughter
went to college yes okay but mom is
being daughter has has been sentenced to
five months in prison for her role in
the college admissions scandal she this
is a big deal because I mean obviously
you know justice being served one to hot
pockets heiress like so Gretchen weiners
and three the crime is kind of similar I
think to what Lori Loughlin did and I
think that it's like a pretty good
precedent for what might she take a deal
or did she go to trial um I believe that
she did not take a deal interesting I
mean I think that the hot pockets
heiress would be richer than Lori
Loughlin right her yeah so like this is
the best legal team like it's just as I
tell like she was at a disadvantage like
she's in a really similar position yeah
her family developed the wildly popular
microwavable snack before selling their
company but she oh she had pleaded
guilty to conspiracy to commit wire
fraud and conspiracy to commit money
laundering in the far reaching College
in Michigan so she took a deuce so she
yes
so she okay so though she didn't so
similar no but it means that the minimum
sentence probably Lori Loughlin will get
is at least five months yeah because
they don't take lightly wasting the
Court's time no no they do not or you
know she could fight it find a loophole
right well I actually had such a
realistic dream last night like that I
woke up in a sweat that I was I I
accidentally murdered a child think it
was really was an accident but my
problem was is that I didn't tell the
police like I ran and then they they
found me out and I was going to jail and
like Zack Shapiro was doing everything
in his power to like not get me to go to
jail and I was so scared of being in
jail like I was just like crying in my
bed the whole night and I woke up and I
swear I have never been so [ __ ] happy
to have so I get up and go to work like
I had a newfound excitement for life and
you know up it's pretty appropriate
because Alexis Neiers is gonna be here
and she spent a month in general a month
yeah Wow I just looked it up and I would
love to talk to her about it like was it
horrible yeah I mean we'll find out in a
few minute and my worst nightmare is
going to jail I think I would rather be
dead our fifth and final story would you
rather be dead I don't know I think
I don't know I think I would but I
haven't spent much time thinking about
it honestly I have our fifth and final
story is a little bit of business
because Bob Iger is out at Disney and we
with in one fell swoop he's out Bob
traffic is in and it's just crazy ya
know it seems very weird because to me
when it happens as quickly and they have
a replacement in the announcement it's
just like here not like he'll be
stepping down next year just in and out
in one day it makes it seem like there's
a red flag like something is going on
100% but we know for a fact that Bob
Iger is the best CEO on the planet and
he's still staying on as chairman of
Disney parks yes but chairman is like
you know it's like in younger when
Charles because chairman becomes
chairman amidst a figure right but if
you're disgraced do they don't keep you
on the ball no I don't think this is a
disgrace you know I'm getting a just
crazy vibe from the way that it went
down agreed but I don't think but I
don't think it's a disgrace vibe no me
neither
I don't I think something's gonna gonna
happen like a merger no like he has
other plans at it he's got some big big
plans I don't [ __ ] know so this was
posted in the toasters and actually
toaster who worked at Disney said he was
supposed to step down in 2014 but they
couldn't find an appropriate replacement
for him so he stayed on and then he did
an interview like last year saying that
he wants to step down in 2021 so I guess
we're not that far off yeah that's been
the CEO for a really long time he'll
lead the board through his contract end
in December 31st 2021 oh yeah but he's
right on track yeah but he's not like a
chief executive officer he's so cute and
so rich like he's I don't know why like
there's we talked about many businessmen
Bo here on the show but like something
about Bob Iger I'm like really attracted
to his spirit yeah me too it might be
like the spirit of Walt Disney yeah you
know but also like he is a CEO who
ushered Disney into a very modern era
Disney pluses everything of this where
people are loving in him in the Streamy
war time yeah it's hard to stand out
yeah with the kwibi 's of the world like
it's hard to be a disney plus yeah but I
actually got Disney Plus because Olivia
got us like a free Verizon or something
and I have really enjoyed it I would
consider the launch of Disney Plus to be
a major success correct yeah for sure
yeah have you used it yet yes I have it
Zack was enjoying it I intend to watch
HSM reboot
just oh I watched Hannah Montana forever
bikini model I mean it's just there's
nothing better there's nothing better
I had another note about Bob Iger but I
can't remember so think I'm just go [ __ ]
myself Bob iger's just so cute is he
married
probably men like that don't stay single
for long
oh my note about Bob Iger I wonder what
this means for Megan and Harry's Disney
yell I hope that ink is dry otherwise
who knows like if they were made
contracting Bob is out you know all
those deals they just we've been in so
many situations course where it's like
someone leaves and you're done change of
leadership yeah and because we know from
that video that went viral of them
talking to Bob Iger at the Lion King
premiere we know that their deal for
Megan's voiceover was done through Bob
Iger yeah so like he's the it's
definitely done because they announced
it you don't announce [ __ ] until the ink
is dry
did they oh yeah they did announce the
voice-over deal okay well I'd love to do
voiceover like I'm watching rewatching
entourage and towards the end of the
show which by the way I have like a
whole problem you remember at the end of
the series where Ari and his wife
separate because she's like so sick of
him like being like work obsessed even
though like he was very loyal and a good
husband and loved her so much and all
his fault it's just that he worked too
much like who [ __ ] cares and he ends
up spoiler alert like [ __ ] Dana
Gordon I don't but then he eventually
goes back to his wife because she takes
him back like honestly his wife was a
[ __ ] and I think he should have ended
up with Dana Gordon and that's all I
wanted to say but Johnny Oh Ari yeah I'm
sorry I always confuse Ari and Vinnie
drew yes yes Ari Oh Oh his wife was
great there's yeah but he like loved her
so much and you like loved that about
him and when he got with Dana Gordon
like they were both on their
BlackBerry's in bed like it made so much
sense thought you were in Vince Deena
Gordon I was like whoa I'm sorry but
towards the end of the series Johnny
starts doing animation animated work for
the show Johnny Bananas and he they're
talking about how being like working in
animation is the best cuz like you sit
in an air-conditioned booth for three
hours a week and like you get paid so
much and we need to get into animation
yeah we do even though I guess
technically we're sitting in an
air-conditioned booth right with five
hours of animating our voices yeah kind
of anyways Vanderpump whirls recap yeah
and then we will bring out Alexis Neiers
Haynes
we had the what's
like the fall back from backlash no and
we're picking up the pieces after the
big fight the the pastor yeah it's uh
it's all-out fallout yes everyone seems
to be on Britney and Jax aside aside
from Ariana and Tom and Twitter and
Twitter Ariana and Tom are really on the
outs this episode and I think that they
were really surprised at everyone not
agreeing with them like when Swartz was
telling Tom Schwartz was the only one
who really got through to Tom Sandoval
being I do just apologize dude just
apologize and he actually ended up did
like sending it I'm like a very sweet
text but I think that he thought he
would like be the hero and literally
nobody thought of him as that well I do
think I mean according to Twitter Ariana
and Tom Sandoval are sorry for being my
mic are the only like real ones on the
show but he's yet to answer a very
important question and even Andy like
touchdown and watch what happens live
last night and he really didn't have a
response which is like it bothered you
so much why did you wait until the
situation was resolved to say something
right as they got closer you're saying
it was six months going on like say it
five months out especially off camera
not 10 days before their wedding when
they were ready when they've already
done the right thing and now you just
want to make them look bad I totally
agree and I just um I can't believe
people think like Tom and Ariana are the
only real ones on the show I didn't
really know that all the girls felt that
way about Ariana like I've always felt
that there was something off in in her
place in the group because all the girls
even Lala who's like new to the group is
like best friends her husband's best
friends like they're all so close and
Ariana has like never been like that but
also Ariana didn't sign up for this show
on her own accord like she fell in love
with Tom Sandoval and she became a part
of the show and people really liked her
and I think she liked being part of the
show but like everyone else like
actively wants to be on the show and I
feel like I feel like they should not
like obviously the show she doesn't like
the people on the show and I don't think
it's good for her and she's obviously
like not in a great place and I just I
think the whole cycle of things and she
shouldn't have to hang out with these
people who she can't trust and that
bring her down and that she feels like
she can't be herself around I mean I
think that's so fair of her to feel that
way but I think that they they need to
make a change because it's not working
yeah no but mom stand of all would never
know no oh my god of course he thinks
he is like literally the main character
yeah so I think that's like this
sticking point yeah because I think if
it was up to her they would do what
makes her happy they made their money
and like they're good yeah so I think
that's something that will confront like
next season yeah but just in watching it
I just my heart broke for her me too and
it must be so much pressure to like not
only have to hang out with these people
who you can't who you don't see as your
real friends like she said she has so
many people that she hangs out with the
things said she's cool as [ __ ] not only
need everything out with people that you
don't like you can't be yourself around
but you feel like judged oh and then you
have to watch all of that on TV and be
judged again here like the voices and it
makes complete sense why she wants to
leave her life yeah it was really sad
that she was just crying Elser like she
wants to drive when she tried when she
went to tell Stassi and Lala and I think
I mean it's just hard for her and I do
feel like she doesn't know that she can
trust them but I personally think that
yeah I thought Lala's reaction was so
genuine laws like I know exactly I've
been through that even Stassi was like
I've battled with my own bits of
depression like I feel like she's not
willing to trust the girls and that's
her right to do so but I think that they
reacted in a really nice genuine way and
then even she went over to Tom was like
it was so weird like no it wasn't they
were actually being so lovely yeah I
just think she has like major trust
issues yeah I think she's like
preconceived notions that maybe they
have a hive mentality when it comes to
dumb [ __ ] yeah
but I think at the end of the day when
someone is feeling down like they would
be there for each other okay so they're
the only other people who know what she
this situation that they're all in like
being in the public eye right on camera
and it was it was sad
it was just really saddening and I
really felt for her but it's not to take
away from the other you know more
[ __ ] storylines right where Tom is
he's not happy for his friends I know oh
my god everything about him he can't
apologizing you know what like what he
did whether you agree with it or not
it's not the biggest deal in the world
it's forgivable but like your friends
getting married in one week you just you
just say sorry even if you're not sorry
I did feel like it was definitely like a
stretch to not invite him to the wedding
like you could demote him from groomsmen
just to regular guests I think not
inviting him I get what Jax was trying
to do like Jax was really trying to make
a statement like I'm not
okay with like in the way you've been
acting it wasn't just this one thing it
was a lead-up of a bunch of [ __ ] but
like I totally get why Ariana's now like
feeling conflicted if Ben was like
disinvited from a wedding and I was like
friends with the girl I don't think I
could go no I don't think I could go
either I totally understand why she's
having a hard time deciding if she
should go you were at the wedding was
Tom Sanibel there you know I'm trying to
remember cuz I don't remember I feel
like you said that he wasn't meet a
really long speech him and Tom Schwartz
made literally the longest speech yet so
he winds up going so they and I
literally I'm sitting like front row at
the wedding like not the ceremony I was
like literally the last person there but
like my seated table was right in front
of the dance floor right where all the
speeches was like I am a hundred percent
sure like me and my shiny dress I might
be on I'm so next week is the wedding oh
and I did sign a waiver like on the
Friday night before like they all went
to a bar like this engagement thing and
Kristen Jodi like invited me to sit with
her who like I was so grateful for and I
definitely got a camera cuz one of the
PAS or something was a toaster and she
like totally hooked me up wow that is so
excited yeah um I can't wait to see that
there were also some other big things
that happened
Lisa cried I've never seen her cry oh my
god heartbreaking I know she can't catch
a break I felt so sad for her I feel
just like disassociated from the Lisa
Vanderpump of Beverly Hills me too
I felt like the woman I was watch our
cry before and that's like what Eileen
Davidson was like trying to get out of
her that one weekend when they were in
mile but were something like what keeps
you up at night
what do you like she's really like this
kind of callous person who you can't get
beyond those walls and just seeing her
cry like even for one second a weirdly
made me like her like it was like I'm I
can now feel empathy for her she doesn't
feel like a robot yeah I totally agree I
don't think I've ever seen her cry I
felt very strongly for her and I am able
to disassociate because it's she's two
different people on both shows yeah and
it's that is what it is she in a
storyline like the second the commercial
break came back and we were like in
Gina's car I was just like I roll I'm
just the storyline is so silly like that
girl Charlie actually she's like cute
and funny he's being kind of funny and I
didn't I didn't just like her I didn't
just like her they shouldn't give me
disgraced manager yes Brett and telling
him what scheana said and she never said
this is a secret and also like don't you
want to know that your friend is talking
[ __ ] about you to the guy you're going
on a date with it's like these two
morons can just go okay I'm like so
uninterested in the Brett storyline but
I love the max storyline okay I'm so
uninterested in the Brett's
and I'm even more uninterested in him as
Lisa's trainer oh thank you do whatever
she pays him to do it's so dumb they
totally like having security it's so
easy but the max and Dana relationship
like starting to fall apart I'm not okay
with yeah but she'll be fine and you
know what she I don't think they're a
right fit like I want to see her with
someone like totally more fabulous yeah
um also Jack's asking Randall to be his
groomsmen was so cute
being in Randall and Lala's house and
like seeing their relationship I
absolutely loved every minute of I can't
believe we're like getting inside you
know you know it's fight like we their
husband guys we've been through so much
we have but what Jack said at that
dinner about Ariana's bisexuality I was
really disappointed in his comment he
also said something like that when I
went to see him at watch repens lives
yeah and it's just not unacceptable
agreed and I'm sure he'll have to answer
for it at the reunion and he needs to
understand that that's just and that's
part of the reason why I think Ariana
just can't relate to this group because
I think of all them she's probably the
most like woke and like aware of like
what's going on around her and I think
that maybe she can trust and she if she
wanted to dive headfirst into the group
like she could but she just doesn't want
to because of things like that yeah and
I respect that yeah that's fair yeah
anyways it was pretty good episode and
then watch what happens live you've got
to see this it was kind of boring but it
was fine even a boring episode of
Vanderpump rules is a good episode of TV
yes Stassi like wasn't on it
neither was Katie with the lizard like
that was dumb I don't know it was like
after I saw that dinner of Randall Jax
lalla and Britney and it was so
everything like I special I wanted I
could then they showed like bouquet like
someone else random I was like Tom Tom
I'm like get out here come back to La
La's house okay we're gonna bring out
Alexis Neiers if you have questions for
her about her book recovering from
reality or anything her podcast head
over to our YouTube leave a comment our
segment with Alexis Neiers is very
appropriately brought to you by talk
space we all have something we want to
change about ourselves whether it's
spending too much time on social media
or wanting to start a new hobby but if
you're like us like most people taking
action can feel impossible without the
right support when you're busy like we
all are the first thing that falls to
the bottom of the list tends to be
taking care of yourself people tend to
say they don't have time or money for
things like that
but talk space is an online therapy that
is the most convenient and affordable
way to make lasting change in your life
with the support of a licensed therapist
send your licensed therapists texts
audio pictures messages videos from your
phone or computer whenever you need to
even if it's on the way to work you
don't have to make appointments or deal
with extra commutes everything happens
in the talk space secure platform on
your schedule they match you with a
licensed therapist based on your needs
and preferences they have thousands of
licensed therapists trained in over 40
specialties you have something very
specific you want to work on they'll
find so the right thing for you once
you're matched you can begin therapy the
very same day a lot of people think
therapy therapy is just about analyzing
dreams are digging into painful memories
but it's also a great tool for
developing coping skills dealing with
stress and getting the accountability
you need to achieve your goals if you
want to get a great deal on talk space
you can get $100 off your first month of
talk space to match with your perfect
therapist to go to talk space calm or
download the app make sure you you use
the code toast to get $100 off your
first month and show your support for
our show that's TOA st is the code at
the link talk space.com we are going to
be back in just a few moments with
Alexis Neiers take a break go get a
snack see Sally at the water cooler and
we'll see you in a minute
Nancy Joe this is the morning toast
calling we are back with icon reality
star podcaster and now author yes Alexis
Haines welcome to the morning to us we
have been dying to podcast with you I am
so stoked to be here I don't think you
know like how much we like we're
affected by your show like we loved
pretty wild we were sisters you were
sisters like we really loved like that
vibe that you had and so it is and
obviously the show ended up being
something totally different than I think
what you guys like before signed up for
but man do you ever rewatch it I've
watched so when it came out I hadn't
watched all of the episodes I have since
watched all of the episodes is it
painful it's not it's funny I find it
okay because we thought it was amazing
no I bagged then it was obviously really
painful but now that I've been through
the whole you know reality show process
and I understand how it works back then
I was very naive I didn't understand it
yeah and the editing and all that stuff
and now I'm just kind of like this is
great yeah well back then how did the
show like come to be what was it
supposed to be before you know
everything went down my sister Tess and
I were basically highschool dropouts I'm
really grateful that I have my degree
but it was like barely there you know
and my mom was this kind of like free
spirit and she really wanted us to get
into the modeling and acting world since
we were very very young and I go into
great detail about that in the book
recovery thanks for the plug babe I'll
take it I know but you know we started
working on like tumor from model mayhem
everyone had a model mayhem okay so we
started working these like weird photo
shoots and at the time I was only 17
Tess was 18 and I think Gabby was like
14 years old and so we were going out on
these shoots doing Marilyn Manson music
videos and tests would have just tested
for Playboy and we were hanging out with
Kid Rock and partying in this crazy
lifestyle and one day we were working
a movie and the producer came up to us
and was like you guys are such a riot
you should have your own reality show
and it was that easy
Wow which is crazy because getting a
reality show is like a one-in-a-million
shot right but for us and I know this
might be a little woowoo for everybody
out there but we had been saying
affirmations every single day that's
true actually like that is what people
do now and they staged their house but
you guys were doing that in like 2000
yeah and 10 yes we were the house
growing up that had life-sized Buddhas
and crystals everywhere and it always
smelled like pot and everybody's parents
were like you're not going over to
Alexis house and now I walk into every
house in Malibu
and it smells like pot and everyone's
got their yoga mats there's 10,000 pound
crystal amethyst in the walkway so funny
so you know we were there definitely
before the time for school but yeah so
it just it ended up working out and so
we shot a sizzle reel and we were
basically like the alternative crunchy
version of the Kardashians
right and the soul the show sold really
fast it we had a bidding war between a
and E and E and well went for it so
legendary
yeah I am - Thank You Chelsea Handler I
know you might hate me but I'm wishing
involved in bagging show uh she was the
producer so she's the one that kind of
like greenlit it for us she pushed for
us and while at the end of the day
pretty wild was a fiasco
two days into filming I ended up getting
arrested and the rest is pop culture
history and by the way that was not
staged show no like when they knocked on
the know that was a redo oh boy that was
a redo a lot of people don't understand
how fake reality team right yeah that
was definitely a redo when the real SWAT
team came to my house it was not even as
nice as that was right it was brutal did
they make you stop filming or you
weren't filming at that time oh yeah
they everyone was out of the house it
was a crime scene and I and I was so
high I didn't even realize that because
what people don't know is there's a lot
of misconceptions I was not the bling
ringleader right oh that's what the
movie made why my house they well all of
media minutes
that wake has sex sells right right
having a reality starlet mm-hmm
being the leader of the bling ring goes
for a lot more time in media than having
just some kids from Calabasas
right and so you you said you were high
at the time you talked a lot about
getting sober yes tell us what that
journey was like like at what point cuz
you were on trial do you have the show
and then you ended up doing time in
prison right
I did some jail time yes I did and it
was the best thing that ever happened to
me really in my life I people ask me
often like if you could go back in time
and change it all would you my answer is
no because the literally and this is not
to brag but the thousands of people that
I've been able to help get sober and
create big beautiful lives for
themselves because of my platform and
because of my experience I wouldn't I
wouldn't have it any other way and
that's not to say that I don't have
remorse the reality is that I was at
Orlando Bloom's house that night I
wasn't The Bling Ring mastermind but I
grabbed that bag I stuffed it full of
[ __ ] I go through this in the book the
other house I'm sorry yes okay so you
know but the the real truth is that I
was a broken child I had been being
basically raped from the age of five to
seven I grew up in a household with
divorced parents where there was a lot
of alcoholism physical abuse and
violence and so what people were seeing
on the outside was this like really
emotionally unstable wild party girl but
what was on the inside was this really
broken scared child and so I began using
drugs when I was 12
Wow and yeah twelve don't mind me asking
started with just like alcohol
cigarettes and weed by the time I was
fifteen I was fully addicted to opiates
and by the time I was 17 I was using IV
heroin and by the time I was 19 so on
the show I was high using heroin every
single day while we were filming Wow
what are the logistics of that how do
you like cuz how do you know look I I
never would have thought that I look
back now
I can clearly see that I'm like hi and
nodding out but I know how to like tell
that behavior and I feel like the vast
majority of Americans especially back
then didn't and you know now opiate
addiction is a huge problem in the
United States it's I you know just
destroying communities all over this
country and it's an it's heartbreaking
so yeah basically we got so good we knew
how to turn off our mic packs we would
go into the bathroom and at that point
during the show I want to correct myself
I we were smoking heroin cuz we couldn't
have track marks on our arms so we were
smoking either oxycontin or heroin off
of foil and between our our filming you
know and it was crazy and and a lot of
people think about the episode of pretty
wild when we're melting down in Cabo and
thinking that I'm crying about Javier
but I'm really crying because someone in
production flushed our drugs and when we
started going through detox in Mexico
and we're stuck in another country
without drugs and that detox is like the
most painful thing ever right so I just
want to make it really clear like I have
a lot of remorse for all of my actions
in my life that harmed other people hmm
and so when I say that it was the best
thing that ever happened to me it's not
without that content of course but it it
did it saved my life like I would not be
alive it's like in a weird way and I
know this sounds odd but it's like being
at Orlando Bloom's house that night
saved my life I understand like I would
not have gone so and not just my life
but now you know we've got the book
we've got the podcast where we're
talking about mental health and we're
talking about how to overcome any
adversity whether it's divorce or having
children with special needs or whatever
we have a platform now for people to
come and share their experience we've
got like my online courses that I offer
now to help support people and then I
own a drug and alcohol treatment center
I'll house recovery centers where
literally we have helped thousands of
people get sober right so it's like all
of this was birthed out of the year
and it was perfect so at what point in
the timeline did you start to get sober
so I ended up taking a plea deal because
I could not I could not go to on trial I
was such a mess and so I took a plea
deal and I went and I spent a summer in
jail and in jail how long was the JIT
the term six months but our and then we
can go down the rabbit hole we shouldn't
though right now but of the for-profit
prison industry and how that works but
mass incarceration there's so many
people that you only end up serving
about 10 to 15 percent of your time and
so I spent the summer in jail Wow and I
got out after like I think 49 days or
something I'm crime I was in protective
custody so I was by myself 24 hours a
day in a jail cell I got one hour out to
shower and in that moment it was clear
to me like heroines a problem Reb like
this is not sustainable yeah but there
was no like maybe you should go to rehab
or maybe we should see a therapist it's
like my family no one had gotten sober
before nobody knew what that was and so
I got out I started getting loaded right
away all of the shame all of the
feelings of like self-doubt of I'm not
worthy I'm unlovable and now I'm like
this public mess and everybody hates me
and so like the needs were my best
friend yeah and then I got arrested
again for possession of heroin and at
that point when I went back into jail I
realized that it's not the hair when
that's the problem I'm the problem and
so what began as like oh maybe
substances are an issue it was like no
you're the issue and thankfully Peter
Espinosa I'll say his name again and
again and again that judge saved my life
he sentenced me to a urine treatment
instead of six years in prison which is
what the DA was advocating for since I
had violated my probation right that
saved my life that's crazy oh my god
that's amazing I literally just got
chills - thank you so much for being so
open and sharing all this I it's like
I'm on a mission girls yeah we're on
image pop culture I love I'll dive into
The Bachelor
I love it oh I love it love it love it
and as someone who is like a part of the
trash operation of our culture like I'm
he I'm here for that part of it of that
love go here for that but it's like now
I'm on a mission because when half a
million people have died from drugs and
alcohol in the last 10 years
I can't stay silent yeah I can't stay
silent when it really crazy could have
been you when it could have been me yeah
and I mean like test overdosed in my
arms like I we had so many close calls
it's like it's not even I've been held
at gunpoint I've been raped I've had so
and it's like you know it could have
easily been me well that's so crazy
well how's your relationship with your
sisters now it's complicated okay
my relationship with Gabby has gotten so
much better she had a lot of resentment
because it is true that like all of my
issues really stole her childhood yeah I
didn't get to have a normal childhood
and then I could obviously argue well I
didn't either like crazy parents right I
didn't you know um but it's gone so much
what if she's pregnant we just found out
Gabby
she's 26 that's nice she's nine weeks
pregnant and I cannot wait for this bit
I get emotional like talking about it
just like so Abby first she's been
married for two years Tess is
challenging she moved away I kept trying
to help her get sober and she ended up
moving to Wisconsin and has been doing
amazing it's been a challenging
relationship regarding the book because
I gave her the opportunity to read it
before it came out and she said she
didn't want to and then when it came out
she was not happy what's up in the book
which is frustrating because it's like I
gave you an opportunity to like read
this beforehand right but you know at
the end of the day I want nothing but
the very best for her and I felt like I
was more than fair and I have left a lot
of stuff out and I did that because I'm
this book is not about hurting people
it's about an inspirational story it's
not how we heal yes so it's it's
challenging for sure and was it
challenging to write the book like
you've come so far like I don't even
recognize you as
Alexis Neiers like you really are Alexis
hey you know and I can imagine that
having to write sit down and write about
the most painful parts of your life was
difficult yeah it was but the hardest
part for me was the editing was having
to hide my rapists names right Wow uh
you know was having like cut a lot of
the leg more like brutal stuff yeah and
I'm like you know [ __ ] them like Jess
you know what I mean I should be able to
see what I want yeah but you know we
have a system in place that just you
know definitely needs some work
especially regarding childhood sexual
abuse totally oh yeah so it was hard for
sure where could everyone get the book
everywhere yeah you know you can get the
book on Amazon so it's interesting I
self-published the book because every
publisher that I went to wanted a Bling
Ring book right and I was like do you
not know how much more interesting the
story is like you guys are missing so
much yeah and so I said f it I'm just
gonna self publish and so I wrote the
book yeah and I frickin self should buy
it on Amazon I have a question for you
about the planning for a moment what
aside from it being holistically I'm
factually incorrect what did you think
of the casting as Emma Watson to play
you so I haven't seen the movie oh
really
yeah I actually think it was that good
like just looking at it from like a
movie not from like a I know that this
is true or this isn't you're just
looking it's like a fan of movies I
didn't think that it was pretty wild
yeah and a fan of Emma Watson hey yeah
um I think that the way that the movie
the movie really it had an opportunity
to really show what was going on in our
lives like with each of us I think we
all were subsidy lling with substance
issues and I don't I can't speak for
everybody but I have talked recently to
somebody who's a member who I'd never
spoken to before they had talked about
that and so I just felt like it was kind
of lacking like the depth that it needed
and it was really just this kind of like
pop culture II like we didn't take it
seriously and the truth is that I think
we were just so caught up in all of it
and what's crazy is that there's been
many more lingering crews since then
right now there's a whole string of
teens that are on trial for doing this
again well and it will never get the
coverage that it got with the bling ring
I think that the show really
sensationalized it I think that we were
at a time where we it was like the shift
where we thought celebrity was
untouchable and then all of a sudden it
wasn't yeah and it was like everybody
had access to these celebrities so it
was definitely an interesting time in
pop culture history
I completely agree and really quickly I
think most I love that you are like so
open about what you've been through but
you also can poke fun at it when it
comes to Nancy Jonas is the lesson I was
calling which I feel like took a lot of
like definitely healing and therapy for
you to get to this place but I like I'm
living for the fact that you and Nancy
Joe are still at odds we are I gave
Nancy the opportunity to come on the
podcast and like let's hash it out
iconic I wanted to have a moment where
we could talk about the way that women
are portrayed in media and often
villainized and sexualized over men and
which is what she basically or not
basically that's what she did in her
article she talked about the shoes that
I was wearing and even though like it
turns out that she lied about that and
we know that $1 uh they were $29 little
bebe brown kitten and all of that you
know I just I wanted to have a moment
where it's like okay here we are ten
years later like let's dive into this
stuff and she was clearly not ready and
so when she wrote this like rebuttal
piece or this follow-up Vanity Fair
piece a few weeks ago I went to town I
put up all of the screenshots on my
Twitter of our DMS back and forth
I put the court records she started
claiming in our dm's that I was involved
with all of the burglaries or more than
burglary and then I literally have court
documents were in Nick Prugo who was the
bling ring leader said alexis was only
involved with one house like crazy she
just like makes up whatever she wants to
make up and I just don't understand how
you can be like a journalist well yes
actually integrity no enemy you would
think that that there would be above
that but they're not I know and so I'll
go to toe to toe I'm never gonna get
invited to Vanity Fair arcs we know
that's not gonna happen um although it'd
be pretty iconic and migrate the
internet if you guys did so hit me up no
I don't think so much here yeah and they
feel like your book everyone should read
it's called recovering from reality by
Alexis Haynes it's available on Amazon
you also have a podcast called
recovering from reality available
anywhere podcasts can be found yeah
follow Alexis on Instagram I just think
you're awesome I'm so glad that we
finally got to talk to you thank you so
much for chatting with us we're so happy
for you and in our I'm what I said to
you when I said like she's gonna come in
the show I feel like your life you've
lived such an interesting life but I
feel like it's also just now getting
even more interesting I know which is
I'm just so excited we've got so many
projects and the work so much going on
and I'm here for it all thank you so
much for being here thank you for having
gratulations on everything yeah yeah and
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning trust millennium morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so for watching us on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe because
video a thumbs up
we're also available as podcasts in
we're part of custome found so it's
about of identity Republic I heard a
cast box all the places so ever you
choose to listen to podcast find us high
in the morning toast maybe subscribe
leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much tomorrow and
Fridays episodes are gonna be gonna be
available as podcast only we love you
guys so much we'll be back next week in
studio Wow